[Music]
hello i'm your new commanding officer
captain seth dozerman my motto is simple
efficiency efficiency efficiency could
probably just say it once are you making
fun of my stutter
oh uh drift you i don't have a stutter
boom i've already established my
authority through my amazing sense of
humor well done sir
welcome to the nine-nine i'm sergeant
terry jeffords and i'm not interested i
have no use for people i find people
weird and confusing i live my life by
numbers you see this watch it tells me
how many calories i burn at any time
question how many calories you think i
burned walking from there to there you
female closest to me oh uh
three three
[Laughter]
try 0.8 numbnuts i've made promises to
my superiors that i most certainly
cannot keep that's why i need you idiots
to work twice as hard no no strike that
four times as hard no no strike that i
need you morons to work eight times
harder than you've ever worked and your
entire life
i'm having a heart attack
yeah i'm having a heart attack
get back to work
get a doctor holy moses he's alive so i
want to explain what happened back there
i did not have a heart attack the
doctors have informed me that i have a
genetic heart condition my aortic valve
is 16
too narrow
which um lowers my life expectancy from
103 to 64. so sorry sir that's terrible
yes it's depressing
they also informed me that i carry the
gene for webbed feet which is just
interesting more than anything else
but uh when you stare death in the face
as i have it really puts things into
perspective namely that i've been
wasting too much of my time
farting around so that stops now say
goodbye to the fun hilarious laid-back
seth dozerman that you used to love boys
hand them out
the hell are these what the hell are
these these are dozer pads each one is
equipped with a gps system and a
countdown clock to remind you to
complete a task every 55 minutes it also
has backgammon on it which i could not
delete but you are not allowed to play
what happens when the clock runs out
failure failure you are behind schedule
oh that's fun yeah your 55 minutes
starts right
now
captain
everything all right
you tell me
according to your dozer pad four of your
co-workers have been gathered around
your desk the last 90 seconds also
someone named norm scully has been in
the bathroom for the last 72 minutes oh
yeah that means he's about halfway
in regards to the co-workers sir i was
telling them i wanted to get more work
done but all they wanted to do was talk
about my dating life knowing full well
that my true love is efficiency
you know my motto sir
chose before hoes
chose his chores
but
i like you
i could tell from the moment i walked in
here that we were wanting the same
detail-oriented love crunching numbers
bet your apartment's immaculate probably
eat off the floor and i do yeah
i'm gonna handle this for you okay
i'm gonna send out a dozer blast
hey
everyone stop talking about peralta's
personal life dozerblast
over
wow
thank you very much sir and might i just
say that this has been a dozer blast i
saw what you did right there
get back to work okay you two have been
in this evidence locker for hey
what nothing oh
nothing you were just making out with
peralta
there's that candy bar rapper i was
looking for
oh santiago what are you doing here
so i guess it is hoes before it chose
with you friend now i understand why
nothing gets done in this precinct the
detectives are too busy frenching with
each other you know what your little
honeymoon is over
cause as long as i'm here you two are
done and i'm gonna be here a long long
long long long long long long
oh this is a heart attack this right
here this is a heart attack oh it's a
big one
i'm gonna get help sir it's all right
we're getting help
tell my wife
that i love her
work ethic
you